to the geologist tell us it's due to the
folding phenomena which gives rise to
mountain ranges and these Mountain they
prevent the Earth from
shaking we have created the human being
from a minute quantity of mingled fluids
in
[Music]
We Begin today's program with the karat
by brother ashra
muhammadi
[Music]
sh
for
[Music]
th
for
[Music]
so
the translation from
suron
23:
12-22 man we did create from a
quintessence of clay then we placed him
as a drop of sperm in a place of rest
firmly
fixed then we made the sperm into to a
clot of congealed
blood then of that clot we made a fetus
lump then we made out of that lump bones
and clothed the bones with
flesh then we developed out of it
another creature so blessed be Allah the
best to
create after that at length you will die
again on the day of judgment will you be
raised up and we have made above you
seven tracts and we are never unmindful
of our
creation and we send down water from the
sky according to due measure and we
cause it to soak in the soil and we
certainly are able to drain it off with
ease
with it we grow for you Gardens of date
palms and wines in them have you
abandoned fruits and of them you eat and
have
enjoyment also a tree springing out of
Mount Sinai which produces oil and
relish for those who use it for
food and in cattle 2 you have an
instructive example from within their
bodies we produce milk for you to drink
there are in them besides numerous other
benefits for
you and of their meat you eat and on
them as well as in ships you ride verily
Allah has spoken the
truth
distinguished guests of honor
respected
Elders Scholars and scientists present
today our
guest from out of Mumbai from foreign
countries brothers and sisters I welcome
you all with the Islamic
greetings as well as a global
integration and humanitarian greetings
assalamu alayum may peace be on
you I am your host and
coordinator for today's
program the Islamic Research
Foundation strives for Islamic dawa the
proper presentation
appreciation understanding and
clarification of
Islam amongst Muslims as well as
non-muslims reason logic and scientific
understanding have been the bis of all
our programs and
discussions Dr Zakir NY our speaker for
today as far as introducing him in
context of today's
talk I would like to briefly say this
from a doctor by professional training
graduating from the TN Medical College n
Hospital Dr Zakir Abdul Karim nyak has
turned around to make d
the proper presentation and propagation
of Islam as his primary mission in
life the Holy Quran and the Islamic way
of life is his
base
imperfection fully reinforced by the
logic and dynamic analysis of the
complete compatibility of Islam with
scientific understanding and reason Dr
Zakir speaks with renewed righteousness
and infallibility of Islamic
teachings Dr Zakir NY is the president
of the Islamic Research
Foundation he's regarded as one of the
leading international Dynamic orators on
Islam and comparative
religion as far as our topic for today
goes the question arises why did we
choose this
topic religion and
science are two very important factors
in human Affairs and motivations whether
in conflict or in conciliation down the
ages false
religiosity has been at loggerheads with
scientific understanding advancement and
truthful reasoning most religious
scriptures have been assessed by
scientists as conflicting with many
places of the
scriptures with context to scientific
facts you may ask is the Holy Quran too
in conflict with modern
science this needs to be objectively and
knowledgeably
analyzed does the quranic wisdom agree
totally with modern scientific
understanding to logically and
scientifically cross-examine this in
open public the Islamic Research
Foundation is holding this
program and lecture talk on Quran and
modern science conflict or conciliation
by Dr Zakir
Nik after the talk and the question and
answer session we leave it up to you the
audience to decide whether the Quran
conflicts or it conciliates with modern
science for your objective hearing of
his talk and Open Cross examination on
the topic in the question and answer
session may I present before you Dr
Zakir
[Applause]
NY
my respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic
greetings may peace blessings and mercy
of Almighty Allah be on all of
you the
topic of this evening's talk is Quran
and modern science
conflict or
conciliation the Holy Quran is the last
and Fin final revelation of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala which was revealed to
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon
him for any book to claim that it's a
revelation from Allah subhana wa ta'ala
for any book to claim it's a word of
almighty God it should stand the test of
time it should prove it self to be the
word of God in all the
ages
previously it was the age of Miracles
MOA a
miracle is any unusual event for
which the human
beings do not have any explanation
if any unusual event which is attributed
to a supernatural power almighty
God the Holy Quran is the Miracle of
Miracles but for a modern man to accept
any Miracle he will first analyze and
verify it
alhamdulillah the Holy Quran proved
itself to be a word of God 1400 years
ago even today it can be analyzed and
verified and even in future and it will
always prove itself to be a word of
almighty God it's a miracle of all
times suppose a person says that he has
done a miracle I like to give you an
example of Baba pilot who
said that he stayed underwater in a tank
for 3 days and when the reporters when
they wanted to examine the base of the
tank he said how can you examine the
womb of the mother which gives birth to
the
child and he prevented the reporters
from examining the base of the tank will
a modern man accept such
Miracles if such Miracles are the test
then you have to agree with me that PC
sarar who happens to be one of the the
leading magicians of the world he will
be considered as the best God man alive
today later on came the age of
literature and
poetry Muslims and non-muslims alike
they claim the Holy Quran to be the best
Arabic literature available on the face
of the
earth and the Holy Quran gives a
challenge in Surah Al bakar chapter
number two verse number 23 and 24 where
it
says and if you are in doubt as what we
have revealed to our servant from time
to
time then produce a Surah somewhat
similar to
it and call forth your Witnesses and
helpers if there are any besides
Allah but if your doubts are truthful
and if he
cannot and of for short you
cannot then fear the fire which is
prepared for those who reject
Faith whose fuel shall be men and
stones for anyone to try and accept this
challenge but natural the Surah that
produced should be Nar Arabic there are
certain suras which are hardly three
verses hardly three
sentences the Surah you produce should
be in Arabic the language should be as
Divine as that of the Holy Quran as
Noble as the Holy Quran the language of
the Holy Quran is miraculous is
unsurpassable
intelligible it has the highest
rhetoric and at the same time it is very
when anyone wants to praise a
person or want to glorify
anyone he deviates away from reality and
the best example you can see is in the
Hindi movies when the hero praises the
heroine and he tries to please her and
says I will get for you the moon I will
get for you the star the more you try
and praise a person the more you deviate
away from reality alhamdulillah though
the Quran is rhythmic it does not
deviate from
reality there were many people who tried
to produce a Surah like the Quran but
they failed
miserably no one has been able to do it
so far and no one inshallah will be able
to do it till
eternity but suppose if I tell you that
there's a religious scripture who says
in a very poetic fashion that the world
is
flat will a modern man today believe but
natural no because today is not the age
of literature and
poetry today is the age of science and
technology so let's analyze
today the Holy Quran and modern science
whether the conflict or
conciliate the Quran and modern science
whether they
contradict or they're
compatible according to the famous
physicist Albert
Einstein who had got a Nobel Prize he
said science without religion is
lame and
religion without science is
blind I would like to repeat it Albert
Einstein
said that science without religion is
lame and religion without science is
blind I would like to remind you that
the Holy Quran is not a book of signs s
c e n c e but it's a book of signs s i g
n s it's a book of
aats and there are more than 6,000 signs
or 6,000 ayats out of which more than a
thousand speak about
sence there are some
people who will be
satisfied just by acquiring one sign
some people require 10 signs to accept
the truth some may require 100 while the
others even after you produce a thousand
signs to them yet they will not accept
the
truth as far as my talk today will be
concerned I will only be speaking about
those scientific
facts which have been
established I will not be speaking about
theories which are based on assumptions
and
hypothesis because we know very well
that many of times science based on
theories and hypothesis it takes you
turns in the field of astronomy
if you ask a scientist that how was our
universe formed how did it come into
existence so he will tell you about the
Big Bang Theory that initially the whole
universe was one primary
nebula then there was a secondary
separation which gave rise to galaxies
which further
split to form things such as our solar
system which gave rise to planets the
sun and the present Earth which we live
in I start my talk by quoting a verse of
the Holy Quran from Surah Alia chapter
number 21 verse number 30 which
says do not the unbeliever
see the heavens and the Earth were
joined together and we clothe them
asunder this verse of the Holy Quran
speaks about the Big Bang Theory in a
nutshell
imagine what we came to know today the
Holy Quran mentions 1,400 years
ago and the Quran also says in Surah
fter 41 verse number 11 that more over
in his design he comprehended the sky
and it had been smoked and he said to it
and the Earth come eat together
willingly or unwillingly and they said
we come together in willing
obedience the Arabic word used here is
Duan which means
smoke if you ask a scientist he will
tell you that the Universe before it was
formed the celestial matter it was in
the state of
gas and the Arabic word Duan which means
smoke is more scientifically correct
than mere
gas and according to Steven Hawkins
who's a very famous scientist he said
the discovery of bridges of
matter in the space is the biggest
discovery of the
century which gives us undisputable
evidence of the creation of the universe
and the Big Bang
Theory previously the people thought
that the world we live in it is flat and
they were afraid to venture too far lest
they would fall
over it was only in
1577 when s Francis Drake when he sailed
around the
earth he proved that the world was
sperical the Quran
mentions in Sur
chapter number 31 verse number
29 it is Allah that merges the night un
the day and merges the day unto the
night merging is a slow and gradual
process the night slowly and gradually
changes today and the day slowly and
gradually changes T night this phenomena
is only possible if the shape of the
earth is spherical it's not possible if
it's flat if it was flat there will be a
sering change the Quran says inah
chapter number 39 verse number five it
says it is Allah who has created the
heavens and the Earth in true
proportion and he overlaps and coils the
night un the day and overlaps or Co oils
the day unto the night the Arabic word
used is
kaara which means overlapping or coiling
how you coil a turbine around the head
how you overlap a turbine around the
head this phenomena of the night
overlapping and coiling over the day is
only possible if the shape of the earth
is spherical it's not possible if the
shape of the Earth is flat there will be
aing change the Holy Quran further
says inat chapter number 79 verse number
30 it
says and thereafter we have made the
Earth egg shaped the Arabic word come
from the root word duya meaning an egg
shape and it does not refer to any
normal egg it specifically refers to the
Egg of an
ostrich and today we know that the world
is not completely round like a ball
it is geosphere it's slightly flattened
from the top and bulging from the center
it's
geosphere and if you analyze the shape
of the Egg of an ostrich it too is
geospheres flatten from the top and
buling from the center so the Holy Quran
describes the exact geosphere Earth
1,400 years
ago previously we thought that the light
of of the moon is its own light it's
recently discovered that the light of
the moon is reflected light of the Sun
the Quran says in Surah fan chapter
number 25 verse number 61 blessed is he
who has created the constellations in
the sky and placed therein a lamp and
moon having borrowed light Quran
says in Surah yunus chapter number 10
verse number five it is Allah who has
created the Sun as a shining glory and
the moon having a reflection of light
the similar message is repeated in Surah
new 71 verse number 15 and 16 the Arabic
word for sun is Shams it's always
described either a meaning a torch or
wahaj meaning a blazing lamp Ora meaning
a shining
Glory the moon the Arabic word if
it's always described as M meaning
borrowed light or n which is a
reflection of light no way is the
Moonlight described as s or wahaj or
always as M or n that's borrowed light
or a reflection of
light the Quran says in Surah chapter
number 86 verse number
three the Arabic word for the star is
najam is described as sakib its light is
described as sakib it pierces the
darkness and consumes
itself previously the
Europeans they thought that the Earth
Stood dead in the center of the universe
and all the planets including the sun it
revolved around the earth it was known
as the theory of geocentric ISM it was
believed by tmy in the 2 Century BC and
was leave till as late as 16th century
until Copernicus said that the earth and
the planets revolve around the Sun and
later on in 169 Johannes Kepler wrote in
his book astronomia Novia that not only
do the earth and the planets revolve
around the sun they also rotate about
their own
access when I was in school I had
learned
that the earth and the planets they
rotate about the axis but I was taught
that the sun was fixed it did not rotate
about its own
axis but the Holy Quran says in Surah
Alia chapter number 21 verse number 33
it
says it is Allah who has created the
night and the
day the Sun and the
Moon Bon each one traveling in orbit
with its own
motion the Arabic word yes bahun is
derived from the word sabaha which
describes the motion of a moving body if
I say that a man is doing sabaha on the
ground it will not mean that he's
rolling it will mean he's either walking
or
running if I say a person is doing
sabaha in the water it will not mean he
is floating it will mean he's swimming
similarly when the Quran uses the
word derived from sabaha for a Celestial
body it will not mean it is flying it
will mean it is rotating about its own
axis and today we have come to know with
the help of an equipment we can have the
image of the sun on a tabletop and we
see there are black spots and it takes
approximately 25 days for these black
spots to complete one rotation
indicating that the sun takes
approximately 25 days to complete one
rotation can you imagine Quran speaks
about the rotation and the
revolution of the sun 1,400 years ago
which science has discovered
today the Holy Quran says in Surah
Yassin chapter 36 verse number 40 it is
not permitted for the sun to catch up
with the moon nor the night to outstrip
the
day each one traveling in orbit with its
own motion what does the Quran mean by
saying it is not permitted for the sun
to catch up with the moon previously
people thought that the orbit of the sun
and the moon was same but Quran gives
the indication no the orbit
of the Sun and the Moon is different the
question of catching up does not
arise and each of them the Sun and the
Moon they rotate as well as
revolve the Quran says in chapter number
36 verse number
38 that the sun is running its course to
a place theine
for a period DET mind the Arabic word
must means to a place determine for a
period DET mind today science has come
to know that the sun along with the
solar system it is going towards a point
in the universe which the scientists
call as the solar
Apex and it's moving at a speed of 12 m
per
second and it's going to a point which
they call as a point in the
constellation of Hercules
the same
message is
repeated in Sur chapter number 13 verse
number two in Surah f chapter number 35
verse number 13 in Surah lman chapter
number 31 verse number 29 as well as in
Surah Alum chapter number 39 verse
number 5 it says that the Sun and the
Moon runs its cause for a period that
mind the Quran says
inat chapter number
51 verse number 47 that it is we who
have constructed with power and skill
the
firmaments and it's we who make the
vastness and the expanding Universe the
Arabic word m means expanding Universe
the vastness of
space Adan EO who a famous scientist
he
discovered and said that the universe is
expanding the galaxies are receding from
one another which the Quran has
mentioned 1,400 years
ago there may be some people will say
it's nothing great that the Holy Quran
speaks about astronomy since the Arabs
they were very well advanced in the
field of
astronomy I would like to bring to the
notice that it was centuries after the
Holy Quran was revealed that the Arabs
became advanced in astronomy so it is
from the Quran that the Arabs learned
about astronomy and not the vice
versa in the field of
physics there was a theory known as
atomism that atom is the smallest part
of matter which cannot be divided this
theory was propounded
by democrats the Greeks 23 centuries ago
and it was also known to the Arabs and
the Arabic word for atom is
z but today after science is Advanced we
have come to know that though atom is
the smallest particle of matter having
the characteristic of the element it yet
can be divided into electrons protons
Etc so people may think that the Quran
is outdated the Quran does does speak
about Zar and says it's a minute
particle but nowh does it say that it
cannot be divided in fact the Quran says
in Surah saah chapter number
34 Verse number three it says that when
the unbeliever say that the r will never
come tell them it will surely come with
the permission of the Lord who has the
knowledge of the
Unseen who has in his record the
minutest detail of an atom in the heaven
and in the earth and in his record is
propitious things smaller and greater
than the atom so Quran says there are
things smaller and greater than the atom
so Quran is not outdated it is up toate
the similar message is repeated in Surah
yunus chapter number 10 verse number 61
that in Allah's record is
propitious things smaller and greater
than the atom in the field of
geography we learn in school about the
coherent water
cycle this was first
described by Sir Bernard Palace in
1580 and he said how does water
evaporate from the ocean forms clouds
the clouds move in the interior how does
it fall as rain the rain water flows
into the ocean and the cycle is
completed previously people thought in
the 7th Century BC phase of
melus he said that the spray of the
ocean was picked up by the wind and it
fell into the interior as rain people
did not know how did the underground
water the Springs where did they come
from so they thought that due to the
pressure of the Winds on the water the
thrust of the Winds on the water it fell
into the interior as
rain and this rain water slipped into
the soil and and returned to the ocean
through a secret passage the abis which
was known at the time of the plateau as
Taris
people believed in this theory of
desaris even till as late as 17th
century and philosophers like Aristotle
theory was believed till as late as 19th
century that water weaper evaporated
from the soil it condensed in Mountain
Cavern and these Mountain Cavern formed
Lakes which fed the spring water today
we know that the underground water the
Springs it is due to the seepage of the
rain water and the Quran says that in
Sur alumur chapter number 39 verse
number 21 Fe is Town not that it is
Allah who sends down rain from the sky
and seeps it in the sour in the ground
in the springs in the earth and causes
Stone field of various colors to grow
the message is repeated in Sur Room
chapter number 30 verse number 24 Allah
sends down rain and dead Earth brings it
back to
life the Quran says in Sur chapter
number 23 verse number 18 that it is
Allah who sends down rain in due measure
we are able to store it and we are also
able to easily D
it the Quran says in Surah alh chapter
number 15 verse number 22
it
says that we send seating winds wind
impregnating and cause rain to descend
from the sky and give you water in due
measure the Arabic word Lai used here is
the plural of L derived from Laha which
means to impregnate or to
fate the winds carrying the Poland they
impregnate the clouds
and then rain falls the wind causes the
clouds to merge there's condensation
there's lightning and rain falls from
the clouds the Quran describes the
Complete Water Cycle how does the water
evaporate how it forms clouds how it
moves in the interior how it falls down
how it flows back into the ocean in
several places in Surah n chapter number
24 verse number 43 in Surah naah chapter
number 78 verse number 12- 14 as well as
in Surah room chapter number 30 verse
number
48 the Holy Quran
says in Surah n chapter number 24 verse
number 43 that we send Mountain masses
of clouds what does the Quran mean by
saying we send Mountain masses of clouds
today if anyone has been traveling in an
aeroplane he will realize that when the
Aeroplane goes above the clouds and he
looks at the
clouds beneath
he will see that the clouds appear as
Mountain masses Quran has said this
1,400 years
ago there wasn't Aeroplane 1400 years
ago Quran describes hydrology and water
cycle in several places in great
detail it's mentioned in Sur chapter
number 7 verse number 57 in Surah
chapter number 133 verse number 17 in
Surah fan chapter number 25 verse number
48 and
49 in Surah f chapter number 35 verse
number 9 in Surah Yassin chapter number
36 verse number 34 in Surah jha chter
number 45 verse number 5 in Sur number
50 ver number 9 and 10 in chter number
56 verse number 68 to 70 as well as in
Surah mul chapter number 67 verse number
30 the Quran describes the hydrology and
water cycle in great detail
let's discuss the field of
geology today the
geologists they tell
us that the Earth we live
on the outer crust is hard and solid and
the deeper layers they're hot and fluid
and inhospitable for the Existence of
living
creatures the geologist tell us that
outer crust is very thin hardly 1 to 10
miles less than 1% of the radius of the
Earth which is 3,750 Mi and the outer
crust is very thin and there are high
possibilities of it
shaking today geologist tell us it's due
to the folding phenomena which gives
rise to mountain ranges and these
Mountain they prevent the Earth from
shaking they act as pegs as
staks the Holy Quran
says in Surah chapter 78 verse number 6
and 7 it
says we have made the Earth as an
expanse and the mountains as Stakes the
Arabic word aad means Stakes means
spcs which we have discovered today the
Holy Quran says in Sur jashia chapter 88
verse number 19 as well as in Surah
nazat chter 79 verse number 32 it
says we have made the mountains standing
firm there's a book by the title the
Earth which is a very famous book and
Authority in this field which is
referred by most of the universities
throughout the world in the subject one
of its authors name is Frank
press and he gives the illustration of
the mountain in this book called Earth
as veg shaped and he says the function
of the mountain is to stabilize the
Earth's crust and Quran says
that the same
information in Sur Amia chapter number
21 verse number
31 as well as in Surah lukman 31 verse
number 10 and Sur Nel chapter number 16
verse number 15 that we have set on the
earth Mountain standing firm lest it
would shake the Quran gives the
functions of the mountain 1,400 years
ago which we discovered
today in the field of
oceanology the Holy Quran
says in suran chapter 25 verse number 53
it is Allah who has let free two bodies
of flowing water
one sweet and
palpable and the other salt and bitter
and between them there is a bar a
barrier which is forbidden to be
trespassed the Quran repeats the message
in Surah Rahman chapter number 55 verse
number 19 and
20 that it is Allah who has let free two
bodies of flowing
water which meet and between them
there is a barrier which is forbidden to
be
trespassed the Arabic word Barak means a
barrier and the Arabic
statement means the flowing bodies of
water they meet and mix previously the
commentators they could not understand
the two opposite description of the two
bodies of flowing water it says they
meet and mix as well as it says there's
a barrier between them the commentator
of the Quran could not explain what did
this words actually mean it was
confusing
today we have come to know with the help
of
science that there is a slanting barrier
between the two bodies of salt water and
Sweet Water between the salt sea and the
Sweet Sea and whenever water passes from
one sea to the other sea it loses its
characteristic and gets homogenized into
the water it
flows there's a barrier but this barrier
is called as a transitional homogenizing
space or
area both the
waters though they meet and mix but the
characteristics yet remain the same salt
water remains salt the Sweet Water
remains
sweet and this phenomena can be seen in
Cape Point southernmost of South Africa
in Cape Town by salt and Sweet Water
meat but they distinct they don't mix
when they flow across the water changes
its
characteristics similar thing can be
observed in Egypt when River Nile flows
into the Mediterranean Sea as well as
the example of Gulf Stream which starts
in the Gulf of Mexico though it flows
for thousands of miles both the water
salt and Sweet Water they are distinct
and if you're traveling in a boat and if
you pick up water from one side of the
boat and water from the other side
you'll find that both the waters are
different one is sweet and the other is
salty even the temperature
differs even in the area of
giala the Atlantic and the Mediteranean
ocean there is an unseen barrier and
this was confirmed this phenomena which
the Quran speaks about was confirmed by
prophet who is a leading Marine of
USA the Quran asks the people that which
of the favors of the Lord will you deny
in surahman itself chapter 55 this was
then which of the favors of your Lord
will you deny is repeated no less than
31 times it speaks about a sign of Allah
subhana tala about trees about the
heavens and then ask you then which of
the signs of thy Lord will you deny it
speaks about water cycle and then asks
you then which of the signs of th Lord
will deny it speaks about the barrier
between the sweet and the salt water and
then ask you which of the signs of thy
Lord will you deny the Quran in one
chapter itself it's asking its
reader which of the signs of God
Almighty will you people deny it's
spring
you that all these signs from where do
they come
which of the signs will you
deny